Nos dicen: "Los triángulos ∆PQR y ∆ABC son
congruentes. La longitud del lado de cada cuadrado
de la cuadrícula es de 1 unidad", es decir, cada
lado de estos cuadrados es de 1 unidad, "¿Cuál
de las siguientes secuencias de transformaciones
mapea ∆PQR en ∆ABC?". Y tenemos cuatro diferentes
secuencias de transformaciones. Entonces, ¿por
qué no pausas el video e intentas encontrar cuál
de estas secuencias mapea la transformación del
triángulo PQR en el triángulo ABC? Y puede ser más
de una opción, así que pausa el video e inténtalo.
Muy bien, vamos a hacerlo juntos. Primero pensemos
en la Secuencia A que trabajaremos en color
morado. Recuerda, empezamos con el triángulo
PQR y nos dicen "Una rotación de 90° alrededor del
punto R". Primero hagamos la rotación y después el
resto de la secuencia. Una forma de hacer esto es
pensar que una línea como esta ahora se verá de
esta forma, entonces R se quedará en donde está,
ya que estamos rotando alrededor de él, pero P
ahora estará por acá; pensemos que para ir de R
a P bajamos 1 y nos desplazamos 3 a la derecha.
Ahora que hacemos la rotación nos desplazamos 1
a la derecha y 3 hacia arriba para encontrar P,
estamos haciendo la rotación y por lo tanto ese
lado ahora se va a ver así; y ahí tenemos P.
Ahora, Q se encontrará justo aquí: una vez
más hicimos una rotación de 90° alrededor
de R. Después de hacer la rotación, el triángulo
PQR se ve así. Así que tenemos la primera parte;
y ahora nos dicen: "después una traslación de 6
unidades hacia la izquierda y 7 unidades hacia
arriba" . Vamos a mover cada uno de estos puntos
6 unidades hacia la izquierda y 7 hacia arriba,
es decir, si tomamos el punto P y lo movemos
6 unidades hacia la izquierda: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, y 7 unidades hacia arriba: 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, llegamos justo aquí,
este es el nuevo punto P. Si tomamos el punto R
y lo movemos 6 unidades hacia la izquierda: 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, y 7 unidades hacia arriba: 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7, llegamos justo aquí; ahora este es
el nuevo punto R. Después, si tomamos el punto Q
y lo movemos 6 unidades hacia la izquierda: 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, y 7 unidades hacia arriba: 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7, llegamos justo aquí; ahora este es
el nuevo punto Q. Perfecto, en efecto, parece que
funciona: la Secuencia A mapea el triángulo PQR
en el triángulo ABC. Ahora vamos a trabajar con
la Secuencia B en otro color: "Una traslación 8
unidades hacia la izquierda y 3 unidades hacia
arriba"; vamos a hacer esto primero. Tomaremos
el punto Q y nos moveremos 8 unidades hacia
la izquierda y 3 unidades hacia arriba: 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, y 3 hacia arriba: 1, 2,
3; por ahora este será nuestro nuevo punto Q
en rojo. Hagamos lo mismo para este punto R:
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, y 3 hacia arriba: 1,
2, 3; este será nuestro nuevo punto R en rojo.
Y por último, pero no por eso menos importante,
nuestro punto P: 8 hacia la izquierda: 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, y 3 hacia arriba: 1,
2, 3; este será nuestro nuevo punto P en rojo.
Sólo la traslación nos lleva a este triángulo,
claramente aún no tenemos el mapeo completo ya que
hay una transformación más por hacer. "Después una
reflexión sobre la recta horizontal que pasa
por el punto A." El punto A está aquí y la
recta horizontal está acá, entonces si tenemos
que reflejar, el punto A no cambiará de lugar;
el punto R que está tres unidades por debajo de
la recta horizontal, ahora estará tres unidades
arriba de la recta horizontal, es decir, el nuevo
punto R estará por aquí. Y sólo con esto podemos
ver que esta secuencia de transformaciones no
funciona, ya que pone a R en el lugar incorrecto,
por lo tanto vamos a cancelar esta Secuencia B.
Ahora trabajemos con la Secuencia C en otro color:
"Una reflexión sobre la recta vertical que pasa
por el punto Q". Bien, vamos a hacer eso. La recta
vertical que pasa por el punto Q se ve así, al
reflejar Q se va a mantener en el mismo lugar;
R está 1 unidad hacia la derecha de esta recta,
entonces el nuevo punto R estará 1 unidad a la
izquierda una vez que hagamos la reflexión;
el punto P está a 4 unidades a la derecha,
entonces el nuevo punto P estará a 4 unidades a la
izquierda una vez que hagamos la reflexión: 1, 2,
3, 4. Entonces nuestro triángulo se va a ver algo
así después de nuestra primera transformación,
aunque todo esto sea un poco desordenado.
Seguramente tú tendrás que hacer algo similar,
entonces lo haré contigo. Muy bien, ya hicimos la
primera parte, es decir, la reflexión; "después
una traslación 4 unidades hacia la izquierda y 7
unidades hacia arriba". Entonces vamos a movernos
4 unidades hacia la izquierda y 7 unidades hacia
arriba, vamos a hacerlo: 4 hacia la izquierda: 1,
2, 3, 4, y 7 hacia arriba: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
vamos a poner el nuevo punto Q junto aquí. Y esto
parece bastante sospechoso, ya que en la Secuencia
A pusimos el punto P justo aquí. Aunque sea un
poco sospechoso, sigamos: 4 hacia la izquierda
y 7 hacia arriba: 1, 2, 3, 4, y 7 hacia arriba:
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7; entonces R quedará
en el mismo lugar que en la Secuencia A. Por
último moveremos el punto P: 1, 2, 3, 4, y 7 hacia
arriba: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7. Perfecto, funciona;
de hecho, funciona porque estamos trabajando con
un triángulo isósceles. Muy bien, fuimos capaces
de mapear el triángulo PQR en el triángulo
ABC utilizando la Secuencia C. Por último,
pero no por eso menos importante, intentemos con
la Secuencia D, hagámoslo en negro para que se
aprecie mejor. Primero nos dice: "Una traslación
8 unidades hacia la izquierda y 3 unidades hacia
arriba", 8 hacia la izquierda y 3 hacia arriba.
Empezamos aquí, y nos movemos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, y 3 hacia arriba: 1, 2, 3, así que aquí tenemos
al punto Q en color negro; 8 hacia la izquierda:
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, y 3 hacia arriba: 1, 2,
3, pondremos el nuevo punto R en color negro,
y de hecho es exactamente lo mismo que
hicimos en un inicio en la Secuencia B,
por lo tanto P quedará justo aquí. Y después
de esta primera secuencia de traslación, nos
dice: "una rotación de -270° alrededor del punto
A", y aquí tenemos al punto A, y como -270° es
negativo girará en sentido horario. Si pensamos en
esta línea y la giramos 180° en sentido horario,
llegaremos hasta esta línea, y si giramos otros
90° más en el sentido horario, parece que,
en efecto, llegamos hasta esta recta. Así que
esto parece que también es correcto. Una forma
de pensar en esto es que si esta recta se mapea
en esta otra al rotar -270°, este punto R la
acompañará, así que terminará también en este
nuevo lugar. Por lo tanto, también la Secuencia
D mapea al triángulo PQR en el triángulo ABC.
Todas estas funcionan, excepto la Secuencia B.